SARA ROBINSON: The
best way to see
how AutoML Vision and
natural language work
is through live demos.
Let's start with vision.
To show you AutoML
Vision, we'll look
at a model I've built for
predicting the species
of a leaf given an image.
The data for this is sourced
from the Leafsnap dataset,
and our model was trained on
images of 10 different types
of leaves.
Here, in the AutoML Vision UI,
is where I gather and label
all of the images that will
be used to train my model.
I can upload them
directly to the UI,
and I only need 10 images
per label to start training.
The best part about
AutoML is that I
don't need to write any of
the model code to train this.
I can simply press the Train
button to train my model.
This particular model took
exactly one hour to train.
When training completes, I
can take a look at metrics
to evaluate accuracy.
This is what's called
the confusion matrix.
It tells us the percentage
of images for each label
that our model is able
to classify correctly.
Ideally, we'll see a strong
diagonal down the top left,
since this means
our model classified
a high percentage of images
in our test set correctly.
And we can click on any cell
to see specific images where
our model got confused.
Finally, the most important
part of this process
is generating
predictions on images
our model hasn't seen before.
Let's try our model out
by generating predictions
on two images of leaves.
As someone who's
not a plant expert,
I'd probably classify
both of these as leaves,
or, if we're being very
technical, green leaves.
Let's see what our model says.
Turns out these both belong
to different species,
and our model has predicted
both varieties correctly
with over 96% confidence.
Once we have a
trained model, AutoML
gives us access to a
custom REST API endpoint
to make predictions.
If I add more images and train
a new version of my model,
I only need to change the
model ID in my API request.
I am incredibly
excited about AutoML
because it gives
anyone the tools
to build custom models,
regardless of their machine
learning expertise.
You might even say that
AutoML Vision is turning over
a new leaf in the way we build
image classification models.
And although I've shown plant
species classification here,
you could easily build a
model in any other domain.
We've seen our alpha users
build AutoML Vision models
for identifying damaged
products before they're shipped,
classifying
catalog-specific images,
and identifying points in time,
like stages of construction.
But what about other kinds
of information, like text
documents or news articles?
With AutoML natural
language, it's just as easy
to build a custom model to
make sense of written content.
Take donorschoose.org,
for example,
a nonprofit that receives
hundreds of thousands
of proposals each year for
classroom projects in need
of funding.
They currently rely on
a team of volunteers
to manually screen
each submission,
so they published a
dataset to Kaggle in hopes
that a community of
machine learning experts
could build them an
automated solution.
Let's see if AutoML
natural language can help.
Similar to AutoML Vision, here I
can look at all of the examples
in my dataset and their
corresponding label.
The text inputs to our
model our needs statements
from the teachers
detailing the materials
they need for their classroom.
Each need request has
an associated category
to help direct the teacher's
requests to a relevant donor.
The labels used
to train the model
have been assigned
manually by volunteers.
Once the model is
trained, it will
be able to predict the category
of new requests automatically.
To see how our model
performs on new text that
hasn't been
categorized yet, we'll
take the following needs
statement as an example.
My students need
aquarium lighting
for our environmental
clownfish aquaculture project.
Donors Choose needs to assign
the category Lab Equipment
to this request,
which isn't completely
obvious from the text itself.
Let's try it out on
our trained model.
We can see that our model was
able to correctly classify
this as lab equipment
with 98% confidence.
Like AutoML Vision, I now
have access to a custom model
that I can use to generate
predictions on new texts
with one API request.
That's really all
there is to it.
Without writing
any model code, you
can build custom
machine learning
models that can accurately
recognize your own images,
understand the contents
of your documents,
and even translate your
jargon authentically.
They're ready to
use immediately,
accessible through Google Cloud,
and they scale automatically
to meet your needs.